le chef de l'état qui a inauguré ce
matin à paris le 33e salon de
l'agriculture cela faisait 18 ans qu'un
président de la république française ne
s'était rendu porte de versailles
ce retard a été largement comblé car
jacques chirac a parcouru les stands du
salon pendant près de cinq heures soit
le double du temps initialement prévue
sur place nathalie saint cricq normand
d'accès
il faut que ce soit il faut que je sois
des limousins qui viennent vous et
dévoué
jacques chirac est un adepte du salon de
l'agriculture ils y allaient ministre il
y venait candidats il y retourne
président alors il s'agissait
aujourd'hui d'une bonne vraie
inauguration personne n'a été oublié
des dizaines d'enfants embrasser des
centaines de mains serrées d'encolure
flatté jacques chirac est bien écrit
alors ils en profitent
bref du limousin à tahiti des vaches
cochons du madiran au punch cinq heures
pendant lesquelles jacques chirac a
épuisé son entourage et rapide
les agriculteurs